[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الدليل واضح جدا على ان الشرطه تفرط في
اجراءاتها وتقلل من حمايتها لذوي البشره
السمراء على سبيل المثال اذا نظرت الى
عمليات الوقف والتفتيش واستخدام القوه
فانها تجري بشكل غير متناسب ضد ذوي البشره
السمراء مقارنه بالبيت
متعلقا فقط بالحقيقه المروعه بوجود
عنصريين وكارهين للمراه بل يتعلق ايضا
باخفافات منهجيه وفشل اداري وثقافي
[موسيقى]
بدلا من ان ينقلوه الى المستشفى حكموا
عليه بالموت لانهم مقيدوه وبطحوه على
الارض لمده ثمان دقائق مع استخدمهم المفرط
للقوه تماما كما قتل جورج فلوريد في
امريكا
[موسيقى]
مشكله كبيره فنظام الشرطه الخاص بنا مبني
على التراضي والتراضي علاقه ثنائيه
الاتجاه اتحدث الى نساء كل يوم يخشين
الاتصال بالشرطه يشعرنا بالخوف من ضباطها
الذكور